[Music]
our question of the day was i was
listening to the show when you talked
about the types of insurance we need i
started looking on your site and we saw
a shield by the protection by the
providers names what does that mean
well that's the thing we've just
instituted in the last few months what
we figured out was
that when i endorse something like a
smart investor pro and elp zander
insurance churchill mortgage those kinds
of companies which all of those i've
endorsed for decades literally
um that really what the reason you would
go to them
is because you trusted me
and you trusted me because and you
trusted them because i trusted them
and you trusted me to be trusted right
so it was trusted so we started calling
it ramsey trusted
and they put a little shield on these
companies if they're ramsey trusted now
what we do
our team does this
is we will not put a ramsey trusted
shield on someone unless we've done
detailed in-depth
uh
you know vetting on these guys and
they're reliable
they line up with our mission
uh you know they have to be a quality
company that's doing stuff the way we do
it
in order for us to endorse them and put
the ramsey trusted
shield beside them
and so um
you know like the good housekeeping seal
of approval except this one actually
means something i'm not saying that one
doesn't but i really if i am a customer
and i'm buying something the good
housekeeping
i have no idea what that means i don't
know what they did in order if that
window is good housing it might be that
they put it through rigorous testing i
don't know i'm a customer consumer and i
don't know that so i'm telling you what
this is this is a seal that we it means
that we've done extensive work
on that company with that company and we
trust them and the rule of thumb that we
use around here is are they reliable
enough are they competent enough do they
line up with the advice we give here do
they have the heart of a teacher you
know
and are are they going to take great
care of you would i send my own
best friend there
and if they would then we put the seal
on it now i got to be truthful with
y'all i've been on radio for almost 30
years
in the early days we were so desperate
to sell ads
that i endorse things not that we're
evil or bad but i just
kind of cringed when i did it because i
needed we needed the money
and it wasn't a sellout but it kind of
was
because it was like i finally started
asking myself if my friend went over
there would i be okay with that and i'm
like ooh
and i just don't want that feeling in
the back you know that's on the back of
your tongue when you do something like
that and it's like greedy or whatever
you call it i don't know it was just
short-sighted
and um
man i just i hit i hit a point early in
my career i mean i probably
25 years ago or something like that that
i just said you know what i don't need
money that bad
even if i need money i don't need it
that bad
even if we're trying to accomplish some
kind of goal i don't need money that bad
and i don't really care how much money
it is i don't want that feeling that i
would send one of you guys who i've
never met
there
and then if my friend called me well
dave did you really
would you really go to that mattress
company
and if i went ooh no i'd never go over
there i just thought it was a it was
just an ad
but i put my voice on it my reputation
my name on it or one of the other ramsey
personalities did and ramsay then stood
behind that company and we're going ooh
see we don't do that
we just don't do that that's what the
shield means it's trusted it means we
would send our best friend over there
and we'd send anybody that works here
out of our thousand team members over
there and so we feel proud
to send you over there
not to see perfect people because i
hadn't met any of those
except some of you that [ __ ] all the
time
but um
and you're that proves you're not
perfect but um but there's no perfect
people out there and so there's no
perfect companies or perfect experiences
but i am proud to
endorse my friend jeff zander at xander
insurance for over 20 plus years over 25
years i guess it is now
he's become a personal friend all of my
personal insurance is there and if
you're my best friend and you call me up
offline
at my house in the evening dave would
you really go to jefferson yeah i did
and yeah you should go over there so
where you're gonna get the best price on
your life insurance shut up
and they're great people to work with so
i mean that's what the little shield
thingy means
is like would you send your friend there
any of you got a friend that if he tells
you she tells you to go see a movie it's
an automatic no i'm not going that movie
because they have no taste in movies
i've got one of those friends his name
is tom
and if tom says go that movie it's a
hundred percent guarantee i'm not
going he sent me to a movie one time
called dude where's my car
this is his taste in movies
which is a classic cult kind of a movie
now i guess
about a couple of stoners who lost their
car right but um
but uh you know this is tom's taste in
movie so if he sends you there you don't
you don't trust tom anymore for that and
that's how ramsay trusted works we want
to be the opposite of tom's movie picks
trustworthy worthy
of
trust